but we are actually going to dive
straight in with our main story tonight
which concerns the covid vaccines
the end result of the world's greatest
scientists working around the clock to
save countless lives
immortalized in a card we'll all
definitely lose in a month
vitally important but also too big to
fit in any standard wallet
way to fumble at the one yard line
science and look not that we needed it
but this week saw yet another reminder
of just how dangerous kovid is with
cases in india in particular
surging at a truly terrifying rate india
set a world record for daily covert
cases
of over 400 000 and that is probably an
undercount and obviously the world
should be doing everything it can to
help india right now but our best way
out of this mess long term is clearly
vaccines
and it's worth remembering we in the us
are incredibly fortunate
we currently have access to a lot of
vaccines and more than
half of u.s adults have now gotten at
least one dose which is great
the bad news is some vaccination
locations have already gone from having
not enough supply to not enough demand
according to the cdc the daily average
for vaccinations has dropped 20 percent
since the start of the month
a worrying trend vaccine demand
declining in south carolina some
providers left with extra doses and
appointments
for wide open palm beach county health
care district says it is now facing
10 000 appointments for the county's
vaccine sites remain
unfilled since they opened this week
appointments are going unfilled
we've got thousands of appointments
available over the next few weeks
and no takers at this point it's true a
worrying amount of people
are holding off on getting the free
covered vaccine and i'm not saying that
you should immediately get something
just because it's free
i wouldn't recommend getting these old
dolls on craigslist just because they're
free
they're weird broken and they will kill
you in your sleep
but these vaccines could save not just
your life
but the lives of people around you and
it's genuinely dispiriting
that just a few months into the vaccine
rollout we are already at this point and
the problem is
for the coronavirus the herd immunity
threshold
is thought to be between 70 and 90 of
the population
but a survey found that while 60 of
american adults have got or want to get
the vaccine another 18 say maybe
and 22 say no and if you're thinking
well hold on
if every maybe gets the vaccine that
still puts us
at 78 unfortunately that poll doesn't
take into account children
who were not vaccinating right now and
who make up around 22
of the population so we need to get the
vaccine into as many adults as possible
as soon as possible and that means you
really need to get vaccinated
and obviously i mean the collective you
but also you
mike mike in baltimore i know you've got
this on in the background at work on
monday so listen to me
schedule your vaccine mike don't say
you're gonna look into it later just
google
vaccine finder baltimore it takes
seconds here are a list of vaccine sites
in your area
and if you're thinking yeah i'm not sure
i need it joe rogan says i'm probably
fine
look it is true you might not get
seriously sick from covid or indeed
sick at all but you could still
inadvertently pass it to someone who
could then die and before you say
well vulnerable people should just get
vaccinated then the vaccines are only 95
effective mike so they'll probably be
okay but maybe not
also the more the virus circulates the
likely we'll see mutations that make it
more dangerous
possibly helping it to evade the vaccine
completely putting us all the way back
to square one so get the vaccine
mike
the point is there is a problematic
amount of vaccine hesitancy right now
even among people who you would really
like to think
would not need convincing we met robert
gannon before he went in to visit his 77
year old mother
kia who was on a ventilator right now in
the icu
due to coven had she been vaccinated she
was not vaccinated
i think she was being hesitant just
wanting to see how things played out
have you been vaccinated i have not what
would it take for you to get vaccinated
um i'd want to make sure that it's safe
wow there is perhaps no clearer sign
of just how deep vaccine hesitancy runs
than someone in that guy's position
still questioning whether to get it
instead of asking is there such a thing
as too much vaccine
because if not i'm going to keep going
back for injections until i'm around 80
percent
pfizer so given all of that tonight
let's talk about the covid vaccines why
people are hesitant
what their worries are and how they
might be reassured and let's start with
the fact
you can't characterize any one group as
uniformly
vaccine hesitant no demographic is a
monolith
every group will have some who are
excited and others who are anxious and
different groups will be anxious
for different reasons for instance early
on you probably heard a lot about
hesitancy among some black americans
which can be
a real thing even this pediatrician had
reservations
when the vaccine was first made
available to both of you did you both
jump at the chance to get it
no no i mean not me anyway
i am black first in this country and
that has
with it a lot of baggage to tell you the
truth and so then my
public health degree the culminating
experience that i did was related to
the the relationship between black
people and physicians and that
relationship has been a cantankerous one
and so those are the kinds of things
that are deeply embedded and challenging
to overcome
even within someone who's a scientist
honestly
i do understand that we've talked before
on this show about the fraught
relationship black americans have with
healthcare based on both
current bad experiences and the history
of incidents like the tuskegee
experiment where doctors
lied to black men allowing them to
suffer from untreated syphilis over
decades or
as most u.s history students would
describe it something i
have not heard of although it does feel
important to mention
that that doctor did wind up getting the
vaccine and in general
black vaccine hesitancy has dropped fast
another group you might have heard have
high hesitancy rates are republicans and
that is also true
around 30 percent of republicans say
they won't get it and it's
not hard to see why because fears and
doubts about the vaccine have flown
around conservative media
with one of the most prominent super
spreaders being this guy
what about this vaccine why are
americans being discouraged from asking
simple straightforward questions about
it questions like how effective are
these drugs
are they safe do you need a reason to
turn on the vaccine
and what happens if you do turn it down
would you be allowed to fly on airplanes
or go to work or enter the front doors
of madison square garden
oh now they're telling us the vaccine
has a delayed
response okay delayed by how long
they don't say if vaccines work why
are vaccinated people still banned from
living normal lives honestly what's the
answer to that so maybe it doesn't work
and they're simply not telling you
that well you hate to think that
especially if you've gotten
two shots but what's the other potential
explanation
okay it is genuinely weird to see
someone hosting a show on a supposed
news network
and ending every sentence with a
question mark especially
when answers to most of those questions
are out there for anyone who cares to
know so for instance that last complaint
that the cdc still recommends wearing
masks indoors when around vulnerable
unvaccinated people
does not mean the vaccine doesn't work
clinical trials found that the vaccines
are spectacularly successful at
preventing people from getting serious
disease
as for whether they protect you from
spreading the virus
the trials weren't designed to assess
that but evidence so far indicates that
they drastically reduce
transmission the reason we still see
mask and distancing recommendations
is that the cdc is being cautious and
wants to be sure that it is not
spreading around during a
global pandemic
like a frozen dinner duke with a tv show
anyway
i hope that answers at least one of your
gaped mouthed bad faith wonderings
tucker you scrunch-faced fear baboon
and the problem is when people like
tucker raise questions without bothering
to
answer them there is a lot of
misinformation out there
for people to then stumble on
anti-vaccine groups have been
waiting for a moment like this to spread
doubt and the scary thing is
they don't actually need to convince
people they're right
they just need to convince people that
no one is
and that tracks with recent polling
while few believe
specific myths about the vaccine larger
numbers
say that they didn't know whether
particular myths were true
or false for instance only four percent
of people
believe the covet vaccine is more deadly
than the disease
but 25 percent say they don't know
and that is not good because if
anti-vaxxers can simply spread enough
misinformation
to cause people to throw up their hands
and say i just don't know enough to get
the shot
they have already seriously
things up for
all of us and to be clear most people
who are hesitant
are not fanatics or conspiracy theorists
many are just trying to make the best
decision
for themselves and their family like
that pediatrician that we saw earlier
you definitely know people like that in
your life
so i'm actually going to spend the rest
of this piece trying to clear up some of
the biggest myths flying around and some
are pretty easy to debunk quickly like
the claims that bill gates is using the
vaccine to put a microchip
in all of us something his wife had this
response to
i know my husband is not vaccinating
people and putting a microchip in her
arm because
that technology doesn't even exist and
he's never uttered the words out of his
mouth so
okay that wasn't the reassuring push
back to a batshit conspiracy theory
that i had hoped for to be honest we're
not microchipping people because the
technology doesn't exist yet
and my husband hasn't said it out loud
to me why would you put it like that
there are lots of things a husband won't
say out loud to his wife not dark things
just things quiet thoughts a partner
might not be ready to hear
like how sometimes late at night i think
wouldn't it be nice to live in an
egg an egg to be in not just an
oval-shaped sleeping pot i can get an
oval-shaped sleeping pod nobody wants
one of those
i mean an egg a big egg with me in it
or maybe a normal egg and i'm small it
doesn't matter what matters is
i'm in an egg not alone i'm with the
gloop
too it's just me and the glue no opening
no windows
no way to ever know if it's morning or
night so do you know what time it is
all the time egg time just egg time for
me and the glute
sometimes it's warm and that's when i
feel safest sometimes i can tell i'm
being carried or
moved about and it's jarring enough that
i'm nervous but not so rough that i'm
panicking and you can shake me
but do make sure not to do it hard
because remember i'm fragile
i am egg
the point is you can't say any of that
to melinda gates she'd never understand
what wife could anyway for the record
there are no microchips in the covid
vaccine
that rumor is based on the fact that the
gates foundation funded research
years ago which is frequently taken out
of context
in that study researchers looked into
creating an invisible
ink that could potentially be injected
along with a vaccine in order for
populations like refugee kids to be able
to retain
vaccine records without paperwork over
time
the original context was lost contorted
and kind of telephoned its way into
becoming
something something bill gates
microchips on facebook a claim which
if you think about it for just a second
doesn't make
sense because if your main concern is
that bill
gates could use microchips to track you
he can already do that
that's what your phone is now
another more reasonable sounding concern
has to do with
just how fast the vaccine came together
wouldn't want to get it
um i felt like i was too rushed i think
the whole thing has been rushed through
too fast
it kind of came really fast like the
vaccine they made up one really fast it
was done way too quick i just
i don't feel comfortable with taking it
not anytime soon
i think that they're using the public as
guinea pigs
right and that doesn't sound good nobody
wants to be a guinea pig although
i don't really know why being a guinea
pig seems great you can eat a pepper
while wearing the stem
as a little hat run around a tiny city
made of cardboard and best of all
you get to use the guinea pig bridge
[Music]
yeah being a guinea pig has its upsides
that's all i'm saying the infrastructure
alone is
incredible but that is clearly not the
concern that those people have
their worry is that we are being used as
guinea pigs
for a rushed untested vaccine it is an
understandable thing to worry about even
if some express it in less than ideal
ways
tell me why you're concerned six words
testing testing testing testing and more
testing
it's important if you're going to put
something into your body that it's
absolutely and totally
tested i tell you what i admire about
that guy his confidence because
i don't think i've seen anyone more
self-assured than the man who just
promised six words
said seven and counted five all without
even flinching
that guy is so secure in his thinking he
could be wrong about numbers
on camera twice and do it with an
unbreaking smile
but it is worth understanding exactly
how the vaccine was
able to come to market so fast because
researchers had been working on vaccines
against other coronaviruses
for years so when covid19 hit they had a
significant head start
operation warp speed as it was famously
called wasn't about rushing the science
it was about significantly cutting
through bureaucracy
that could have otherwise slowed it down
as this vaccine researcher explains
did you ever imagine that we'd be able
to develop a vaccine in 12 to 18 months
the short answer is no we're able to
compress the timeline
so that things that we would normally do
in a linear fashion
a to b we actually start the f and the a
at the same time as a and b exactly they
took steps that usually happen
sequentially and save time by running
them simultaneously and to be honest
i am envious of that level of efficiency
i would save so much time every morning
if i could shower shave eat
breakfast kiss my family and brush my
teeth
all at the same time unfortunately i've
only ever managed to do three of them at
once but i am
so close to that fourth one now another
concern that you may have heard or seen
online is that the
pfizer and moderna vaccines are the
first authorized to use messenger rna
which is true but that has given rise to
speculation
about what mrna is capable of doing
basically anyone taking these vaccines
they're all designed to the same thing
is going to have neurological disorders
within one year
most of the people taking the vaccine
will be dead within 10. let me tell you
something
you take the mrna it creates plaque in
your brain it gives you alzheimer's and
i got the studies too
so hey you think they just put flora in
the water to dumb you down
man alex jones is having a blast isn't
he
no one else has as much fun while making
the world a worse place to live in
it's like he invented a jet pack that
sprays everyone beneath him with human
but the thing is there is
absolutely no
evidence or credible studies supporting
any of what he just said
as for the claim that mrna vaccines
modify your dna
it is very important to know that the
vaccines mrna
does not enter our genome it does its
work
far from the cell's nucleus which is
where your dna
is but the fear of what the vaccine
contains or what it could do to you
seems to be common
some evangelicals are concerned that it
contains cells from aborted fetuses
which it does not others worry that it
could
change the body's inner workings you
might have had a friend tell you that
they are worried that the vaccines cause
infertility those rumors were fueled by
a blog post
which falsely claimed that pfizer's
vaccine contained ingredients
capable of training the female body to
attack a protein
that plays a crucial role in the
development of the placenta but a few
things there first
experts say of that claim it's a myth
it's inaccurate
there is no evidence to support it and
there is already
pretty good proof that pfizer's vaccine
doesn't cause infertility because
during the trials last year multiple
women became pregnant
and the only one who suffered a
pregnancy loss was given the placebo
so it is just not true and look
the final myth you may have heard is
that the risks from the vaccine are
somehow greater
than the risks of covid that is a
perception fed by the constant
circulation of misleading headlines
about people
falling ill or dying after getting their
shot for instance
you may have seen this story that was
widely shared about 23 people
in norway dying within a week of getting
the shot which does
sound scary but that headline is missing
some pretty major context
while those people did die at that point
in norway the vaccine was being
administered to the oldest
or sickest people and a certain
percentage of them were statistically
going to die that week vaccine or no
vaccine on average
400 people died every week in nursing
homes in norway
and when the world health organization
reviewed those incidents
they didn't find any unexpected or
untoward increase in fatalities which
does make sense
correlation isn't causation the vaccine
protects against covid
not the concept of mortality it is weird
that i have to clarify this but you are
in fact going to die one day mike
yeah mike stop listening to what joe
rogan tells you he's a and
those are his words
not mine that also goes for stories that
you might see hyping up
scary sounding data from veyers the
vaccine adverse event reporting system
it's a database that collects stories
of medical events following vaccinations
but any lay person
has to treat data coming out of it with
extreme caution
because reports can be entered by anyone
and are not routinely verified
one doctor once claimed that the flu
vaccine turned him into the hulk
and that report was accepted and entered
into the database which is completely
absurd
a drug cannot turn you into the hulk
although admittedly it can turn you into
captain america the only superhero whose
origin story is
a metric ton of experimental nazi
steroids
and look if we're just gonna share
random unverified side effects
i might as well show you this truly
shocking video
about what might happen to your mom so
my mom got the vaccine
because she's a healthcare worker and
she told me she's experiencing some side
effects
mom what's that side effect you said
you're experiencing being a boss ass
very good and look i'm not saying veyers
is useless
it very much isn't the reason the cdc
collects this data is so
if a pattern does emerge actions can be
taken that is exactly what happened
with the johnson and johnson shot the
cdc found a potential pattern of rare
blood clots and
paused the rollout under an abundance of
caution
and while some vaccine skeptics pointed
to that as evidence that they were right
about vaccines being dangerous
in reality it kind of proves the
opposite
that the safety risk of vaccines is
rigorously and publicly analyzed
not secretly buried and somehow leaked
to the human football's neon scream hour
and none of this is to say that there
are no side effects to the vaccines
there can be
it is just that serious ones like
anaphylaxis
are incredibly rare 4.7 cases per
million for pfizer
two and a half cases per million for
moderna and you should know
those also occur mostly in individuals
with a history of
severe allergies the fact is
the vast majority of people can expect
at most
typical colds or flu symptoms in the
first few days after they're shot or
maybe
just a sore arm or maybe nothing at all
for what it's worth i actually got my
second shot this thursday
my arm hurt a little bit for a day but
that's basically it
i will admit the following afternoon for
a couple of hours i did feel
a little bit like a boss ass but
that passed quickly
and anyway the key thing to remember is
that
no side effect of the vaccine is worse
than the alternative
covid a disease that has killed over 500
000 people in the u.s alone while once
again
to date the vaccine has been proven to
kill exactly
zero so it is more than natural to have
questions
but there are reassuring answers out
there
and anyone just throwing out questions
without acknowledging that
probably has another agenda entirely but
the problem is to get anywhere close
to herd immunity we badly need to
convince anyone who can be convinced
so the question is how do we do that
while some republican lawmakers to their
credit have tried to reassure their
voters although occasionally
those attempts have looked like this
live free
and beauty surrounds you the world still
astounds you
each time you look at a star
i'm senator john kennedy i can't sing
very well but i'm free
be free be cool get the vaccine
i did it works okay i don't love that
and not just because it is the worst
thing to come out of a kennedy's mouth
since the back of a kennedy's head but
also because the truth is
that probably didn't convince anyone in
researching this piece
experts repeatedly told us that the
vaccine hesitant
generally don't respond well to hearing
from politicians celebrities or athletes
telling them to get the vaccine
and i get that i would love to think
that i could end this piece having
carefully laid out some data with a
triumphant call for people to get
vaccinated
featuring a mascot of some incongruous
animal
know a vaccine cicada you don't think
that that's something that i would be
interested in doing the truth is we
actually did that
we had a vaccine cicada costume made but
after being advised that this technique
would not be remotely effective in
convincing people who were hesitant
we scrapped the idea completely we
emailed our mascot guy and we told him
not to come in because it was an
absolutely stupid idea
a vaccine cicada can you imagine how
dumb that would look it probably
wouldn't even look like a cicada more
like some kind of unhinged cockroach
it was a terrible concept that could
have fundamentally undermined
the very important message that we were
trying to send and i am
so so glad that we avoided making that
mistake
because the truth is i'm not going to be
able to convince the people in your life
who are hesitant
the person with the best chance of doing
that is you
so if you know someone who is worried
for whatever reason
and you want to convince them otherwise
don't show them this video
but maybe do try and use some of the
information inside it
to tell them yourself and when you are
trying to do that
don't dismiss or judge them for having
doubts and i know that that is not
always easy
i could have given that guy a pass for
holding up the wrong number of fingers
but i couldn't do it i don't have that
level of restraint i'm a small petty man
and that guy
is a idiot but if you think you
can do better
it is incredibly important that you try
or
to put in the terms that that guy could
understand i've got two words for you
please just try as hard as you can
you